Please don't!
In a city gripped by fear...
Should I be concerned for my safety?
A woman should always be concerned for her safety.
It's a nasty world.
...three neighbors...
I'm Victor, nice to meet you. Spencer, Louise.
...are getting to know each other.
Car accident. Last winter, my wife died.
Three dead and raped.
There's a lot more detail there.
Why do you think you're so interested in all this stuff?
When everyone is a suspect,...
Were you alone?
Yeah. No! No, no. Louise, you were here with me.
...they'll discover that the real danger isn't on the street,...
...it's much closer to home.
You don't get a serial rapist vibe off of him?
I'm so sorry. It's pitch-black outside, you're coming home by yourself and I just leap out.
I saw him, walking outside that night.
I think we have a common problem, Louise: Victor.
Just moved back to town. He's lonely.
Where were you last Tuesday night?
Home.
How come you didn't tell me you knew that last victim?
Wait, what's going on exactly?
You tell me.
Hi there.
Do you ever like dancing?
I always like watching.
Something's going on with these people.
He's just waiting for any chance to get rid of me.
I have a surprise for you.
Oh, Louise! You always wanna see the best in people, don't you?
Louise?